y
[Música]
francia entra a su tercer confinamiento
nacional y extiende medidas por cuatro
semanas debido a la grave situación
sanitaria del presidente de manuel
macrón también anunció que las escuelas
cerrarán durante tres semanas hoy el
primer ministro jan castex presentó el
nuevo plan ante la asamblea nacional
siete destacados defensores de la
democracia de hong kong fueron
declarados culpables por organizar y
participar en las protestas masivas
contra el gobierno en 2019 dren dentro
de este grupo está el magnate de los
medios holguín y line así como martín
lee de 82 años un veterano del
movimiento prodemocracia de la ciudad
tenemos reporte de es de 20
ante la delicada y tensa situación
política y social en mianmar tras el
golpe de estado del primero de febrero
la onu teme una guerra civil en el país
entretanto hoy la líder demócrata aung
san suu kyi fue acusada de violar la ley
de secretos oficiales del país y su
abogado afirmó que no es claro si su
chip está al tanto de la situación del
país
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si re blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en francia donde en medio de un repunte
de contagios de kobe 19 en el presidente
de manuel macro en anunció un paquete de
nuevas medidas entre las que se destaca
la extensión del confinamiento durante
cuatro semanas y el cierre de las
escuelas ante esto el primer ministro
francés yann castex explicó y detalló
hoy ante la asamblea nacional el plan
anunciado por macro la ponencia de
castex estuvo marcada por las críticas
de la oposición que denuncian lentitud
en la toma de decisiones del presidente
durante el último mes pese a esto los
parlamentarios aprobaron el paquete de
medidas escuchemos parte de lo que
fueron las declaraciones del primer
ministro
la tasa de contagio está aumentando más
rápidamente entre los niños y
adolescentes en comparación con la
población general lo que implica cada
día más cierres de clases y escuelas
por eso los establecimientos escolares
estarán cerrados durante tres semanas
optimizando el periodo de vacaciones de
primavera por lo que los efectos sobre
los niños podrían ser menos
perjudiciales así el ministerio
permanece alerta lengua en penalizar
posible
en el informe que verán a continuación
les contamos en qué consiste el nuevo
paquete de medidas anunciadas por el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón que
entrarán en vigor este sábado 3 de abril
y del que se destaca la extensión del
confinamiento en todo el territorio
durante cuatro semanas y el cierre de
las escuelas
tras los esfuerzos para evitar un tercer
confinamiento nacional en manuel macro
vio reducida sus opciones con más de
5000 pacientes en cuidados intensivos y
las muertes acercándose a las 100.000 en
francia- el presidente alertó que el
país corre el riesgo de perder el
control una situación que ha obligado al
gobierno a cerrar las escuelas por
primera vez desde el final del primer
confinamiento el año pasado
guarderías y escuelas de primaria y
secundaria se cerrarán por tres semanas
pero debemos preservar la educación y la
formación por eso se adaptará el
calendario escolar para que nuestros
niños no estén solos sin acceso a la
educación desde la próxima semana los
niños tendrán una semana de escuela
online y dos semanas de vacaciones de
primavera las medidas de confinamiento
que actualmente tienen varias zonas de
francia incluida parís se extenderán por
todo el país desde la noche del sábado
durante al menos un mes los ciudadanos
solamente tendrán que llenar un
formulario si van a viajar a más de 10
kilómetros de sus domicilios por alguna
de las razones autorizadas todos los
comercios no esenciales cerraran y se
insta a la gente a trabajar desde casa
macrón a rojo sin embargo un haz de luz
al final del túnel
anunció un calendario de vacunación con
el que pretende inocular a los menores
de 50 años a mediados de junio gracias a
las vacunas finalmente podemos
imaginarnos un final para esta crisis
nuestro principal objetivo es acelerar
el presidente también prometió un
calendario para una reapertura
progresiva de los restaurantes bares y
eventos culturales desde mitad de mayo
aunque el retorno a la vida normal aún
parece quedar lejos mientras los
franceses se preparan para unas semanas
difíciles
y comienzan los ritos de la semana santa
para el mundo cristiano a causa de la
pandemia miles de fieles que solían
acudir a estos eventos tendrán que
restringirse una vez más el papá
francisco volverá al igual que el año
pasado a oficiar todos los ritos dentro
de la basílica de san pedro pero con la
presencia de pocos fieles vamos ahora
con nuestra corresponsal en italia a
natalia mendoza natalia muy buen día se
trata de una semana santa particular la
de este año ya que todas las
celebraciones se llena se llevan a cabo
en el contexto de esta pandemia en qué
medida esto ha impactado las
celebraciones de este año
pues raúl mira este año las
celebraciones han sido radicalmente
simplificadas para evitar el riesgo de
contagio antes de la pandemia el papá
francisco solía visitar una cárcel
durante la semana santa esto ha sido
cancelado el tradicional rito del
lavamiento de los pies también ha sido
anulado este jueves santo el francisco
celebró la misa del crisma dentro de la
basílica de san pedro con una presencia
muy reducida de fieles y concelebrantes
el vía crucis que siempre se organizaba
en el coliseo romano pues este viernes
santo se llevara a cabo en la basílica
de san pedro sin fieles en la plaza de
san pedro de san pedro' sin fieles casi
completamente vacía y el domingo el papa
no se asomará al balcón de la basílica
de san pedro para pronunciar su
tradicional bendición urbi et orbi esta
bendición será transmitida en directo
desde el interior del vaticano natalia y
ante todo esto por supuesto tengo que
preguntarle cómo está el ambiente dentro
del vaticano y también el ánimo de la
gente de los fieles católicos
pues claramente es un ambiente muy
inusual este año no se ven en los
alrededores del vaticano las hordas de
turistas que siempre llegaban en esta
época del año para asistir a estas
celebraciones la gente aquí te puedo
decir está exhausta está cansada después
de más de un año de restricciones debido
a la pandemia y seguramente este es un
contexto propicio para vivir estos estos
días y que sea una semana santa más
sobria de introspección que en todos los
casos para los creyentes del mundo
entero este es el momento más importante
del calendario litúrgico católico así es
natalia gracias por toda la información
esperemos que el año que viene pues sea
totalmente diferente vamos ahora hasta
hong kong donde siete destacados
defensores de la democracia fueron
declarados culpables por organizar y
participar en las protestas masivas
contra el gobierno en 2019 que
desencadenaron una ofensiva contra la
disidencia nuestro corresponsal en
beijing adrián foncillas nos cuenta
quiénes son estos detenidos
entre los condenados soy figuran algunos
de los más conspicuos activistas y
políticos de la oposición esta jimmy lai
magnate de la prensa el propietario del
apple daily un tabloide que se hizo
célebre con las chafarderías de las
celebridades locales y que también
ejerce de martillo pilón contra pekín y
el gobierno de hong kong la y está
procesado también por colusión con
fuerzas extranjeras por sus reuniones
con mike pence mai pompeu john bolton y
otros halcones de la anterior
administración estadounidense lay es
considerado por la mitad de la población
japonesa como un héroe y por la otra
como un traidor está también martín lee
un abogado octogenario y exparlamentario
que es conocido como el padre de la
democracia en hong kong porque fundó el
partido democrático la formación bandera
de la oposición y ésta también le un
cojón más conocido como pelo largo por
razones obvias un pionero que ya luchó
contra el colonialismo británico desde
su formación trotskista y que después
tras el regreso de hong kong a china
llevó sus tácticas de guerrilla
camisetas del che guevara al parlamento
en unos tiempos en los que los
pragmáticos con con eses consideraban
una excentricidad las reivindicaciones
pro democráticas y no para la crisis
social y política en mianmar esta mañana
la líder demócrata aún san suu kyi fue
acusada durante una nueva audiencia de
violar la ley de secretos oficiales del
país un nuevo cargo que se suma a la
lista que la junta militar tiene contra
ella su abogado a quien no le permiten
ver a su cliente en persona dijo este
jueves que no es claro si su chip está
al tanto de la situación actual del país
y mientras tanto el consejo de seguridad
de la onu teme una guerra civil en ese
país se anunció más condenas tanto china
como rusia se niegan a condenar el golpe
de estado pero rechazan la violencia
allí ocurrida para analizar lo que
ocurre en ese país nos acompaña a
fernando pedrosa profesor de la carrera
de ciencia política de la facultad de
ciencias sociales de la universidad de
buenos aires donde coordina el grupo de
estudios de asia y américa latina además
dirige la red
hacia américa latina gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros profesor la onu teme
un baño de sangre en mianmar que tan
inminente puede ser una guerra civil en
este país
un día raudo en argentina si
efectivamente ya llegamos más de 500
muertos según se estiman diversas
organizaciones derechos humanos y se se
ha acelerado el conflicto étnico con los
grupos armados que están en el interior
del país y el ejército no no ha cesado
por el contrario ha aumentado la
ferocidad de la represión ya no sólo una
represión en regla con en la calle entre
fuerzas de seguridad sino con grupos
paramilitares con grupos ilegales que
asesinan a personas en sus casas en su
lugar de trabajo así que el pronóstico
yo creo que es muy muy negativo y la
guerra civil está a la vuelta de la
esquina pero en este momento nos
enfrentamos a una de las peores matanzas
que está sufriendo el mundo la
actualidad ahora profesional como usted
también lo decía varias guerrillas
étnicas han amenazado unirse con las
protestas contra la junta militar sino
para las muertes de los civiles se
podría tener futuro una alianza que
junte elementos tan dispares como grupos
armados de distintas etnias y un
movimiento de protestas civiles
es posible que eso ocurra en la práctica
no creo que como un acuerdo explícito
pero mientras el ejército de mía marca y
efectivamente ese es ese grupo mejor
preparado mejor armado financiará sus
programas por rusia con apoyo político
de china mientras eso siga así va a ser
muy difícil poder derrotarlo en el campo
quiero decir como como un elemento
además que el ejército me ama ha
bombardeado ha usado la fuerza aérea
para bombardear ciudades de minorías
étnicas grupos karen en la frontera con
tailandia y eso ha generado también
fuertes migraciones forzadas hacia el
país vecino entonces creo que también la
crisis de mi hermana está a punto de
generar un problema para la región ya no
solamente para su propio país ahora
varios países condenan la violencia de
esta junta militar y algunos imponen
nuevas sanciones que más se puede hacer
por parte de la comunidad internacional
para frenar esta crisis
yo creo que inmediatamente que procede
transacciones la onu tiene que ir más
fuertemente me parece que los países
tienen que intentar que tienen que
intentar nos pueden obligar obviamente
que tienen que intentar que sus empresas
dejen boicoteen las productivas en
miramar y creo que también vendría bien
una fuerte autocrítica de algunos grupos
como amnistía internacional alguna
prensa norteamericana por la forma que
se han dedicado los últimos años en
socavar el liderazgo de sanssouci lo que
se ve ahora es claramente que estaba
haciendo equilibrio con un ejército que
era muy fuerte y así lo entendió también
la sociedad birmana que le dio el apoyo
electoral en las últimas elecciones
profesor usted la mencionaba y es un
punto clave en todo este conflicto que
pasará con anza un sushi y que le depara
el futuro como lo ve
del futuro difícil a conducir no
solamente esta presa no sólo carece de
posibilidad de defenderse ni siquiera
estará informada de lo que pasa en el
país como tú has dicho pero yo creo que
a más personas la persona de más de 75
años o sea que no tiene un futuro muy
muy largo por delante yo creo que los
militares también están jugando con esa
posibilidad los metas son un sector muy
duro son un sector al que no le importa
mucho en la presión internacional a la
que nos importa mucho qué opina la gente
de su país entonces me parece que están
intentando alguna manera barrer con el
liderazgo de súchil y generar una
democracia tutelada donde aparezcan un
político propio a un ex militar que
pueda reconducir la actuación pero esto
dentro de un año cuando ellos se
plantean recién en ese momento se llama
elecciones profesor gracias entonces por
su análisis por estar aquí con nosotros
en francés y cuatro para entender un
poco todo este conflicto político y
social que ocurre en mianmar nosotros
seguimos con más información acá en el
estudio vamos hasta eeuu donde ayer en
el
el día de juicio al expolicía derecho
bin se mostraron al jurado distintos
vídeos del arresto de georges floyd las
imágenes ofrecieron nuevas perspectivas
de lo sucedido y en ellas se ve a los
policías forcejeando con floyd varias
veces antes de que xavi en cara a su
rodilla en el cuello del fallecido
durante aproximadamente nueve minutos
las grabaciones también muestran al
joven defendiéndose de sus actos
argumentando que floyd era un tipo de
tamaño considerable la defensa de joven
sostiene que floyd no murió por culpa de
la ex policía de minneapolis sino de una
combinación de drogas y también de mala
salud pues todo esto ocurre en este
juicio contra el ex policía derecho bin
que por supuesto continúa esta semana y
nosotros vamos a llevarle todas las
incidencias que ocurran
y les recuerdan otra página web france24
puntocom para que siempre esté conectado
con nosotros hay usted puede ver todas
las noticias nuestros programas y demás
hasta aquí el informativo continúen con
nosotros
[Música]
franz mente